hello everyone i'm alana and i have had
the absolute privilege of getting to
play stray early huge thanks to
annapurna interactive for providing me
with a code my webcam is going to stay
uh this big for the remainder of this
video just because this is the review
embargo not the let's play embargo so
while i am going to be wandering around
this little kind of hub world area while
i chat to you guys about it i don't want
it to look like a let's play this is not
a let's play i'm not gonna go through
any story stuff and i'm not going to
spoil anything i will however be
answering some questions i found about
the game from around the internet uh to
give you guys my impressions and an
overall look at what the game is and how
we like it first up uh i love this game
i absolutely love it and for context i
am not
a person who can be swayed by the
cuteness of a cat that
was never going to sway me i knew it
would sway a lot of other people and as
i was playing through this game which
has some incredibly smart design
some very strong world building which is
why i really want to contain what i show
you i think the world building is one of
the strongest parts i never wanted to
stop playing it it's about five to six
hours long probably more like eight if
you're going for a hundred percent and
if you have a day aside i think you
could and probably should do that in one
sitting uh part of that advice relates
to one flaw that i found but i kept
thinking as i was playing it this game
didn't need to be good like people would
buy it based on it being a cute cat game
um his little idol animations are super
adorable here like you didn't need to
make a good video game but they did the
sound design the world building like i
said there was even some stuff that the
internet got me a little bit worried
about um i had heard somebody say that
it has a lot of stealth sections
and it does have some uh parts where you
have to avoid like a security guard
potentially or a drone but these aren't
terribly common this is not a stealth
game it's just a game that occasionally
has some minor stealth segments and i
didn't find any of them to be grating or
annoying in any way they were pretty
simple especially when you're a cat and
you can hide in a box you're often
actually intentionally meowing to lure
the enemies towards you rather than
trying to stealthily avoid them the
second one that concerned me is people
saying it was open world and that is
also not the case it definitely has a
linear story this is just this little
open world section that like i said is
sort of the hub world which i think is
very sweet and there are a couple of
these the one later in game is much
cooler uh which is why i decided not to
spend all my time there so you can
discover it for yourself
um this is me climbing here obviously
climbing is is pretty simple but
a lot of very cute design choices like i
said
where it's like you're just doing silly
cat stuff but it actually ties into the
gameplay really neatly like there is
actually
a mission where you are required to
knock stuff off or several that happens
probably several times throughout the
game you have to knock something off a
shelf to annoy somebody in order to
progress through the story and it's just
like such cute little
pairings of things um that i'm just so
impressed with this on a game design
level really really smart world design
here where it's intentionally
fed you lights and lines to direct you
to the right places and that's so
consistent throughout the story it's so
clear and precise and clean and um
the fact that they managed to execute on
so many of these things like with this
you know scary overrun world that again
i'm going to try not to dabble too much
into because i want you to experience it
fresh but you're playing as a cute cat
and just every single piece of the game
to me really feels like it feeds into
just one very good
cohesive team like a team that is so
clearly working towards a common goal
and no part doesn't match the other part
like
beautifully direct and i don't know if
that's because since i've been working
in aaa game development for a couple of
years now if that's like my brain has
just shifted in a way that i look at
things that way where maybe some
you know just regular non-industry
gamers might not take it the way that
i've taken it but
yeah i found this game like inspiring i
was like god there's so much cool design
stuff it's awesome so to the questions
to what extent is it an open world or
guided experience and it looks like
moving eg jumping is guided by button
prompts is that limit where you can go
um so you're definitely limited in where
you can go um a lot of the time you
can't jump long gaps but you'll have a
much easier time jumping upwards or
downwards like i can't jump on top of
this
uh it's only button prompts and it tends
to
it's mostly only places that you need to
go so you definitely can't climb
everywhere so for instance i can jump
across this
but i can't jump up that
um they have these little cute little
cat elevators everywhere in buckets
which again when i talk about good game
design they've made it made perfect
sense in the world because uh this sort
of robot species actually really cares
about gardening in a way that is very uh
if you've played near automata
indicative of near automotive also for
the record um this part that you are
seeing me play
is
two hours in um because i didn't want to
spoil anything too much so this is just
the hub world that you will return to a
number of times just uh very early on in
the game so yeah this is sort of how the
the climbing works
very very guided for sure
um and the game itself is definitely
very linear but there's often so much
interesting stuff on that path that i
don't see that as a negative in any way
whatsoever does stray have puzzles and
if so are they difficult i would say
that stray is a puzzle game there are a
lot of puzzles quite frequent puzzles
and some of them are just a matter of
trying to break into a room or a
building or a house some of them uh
require
finding things and and getting things
power um others are like i said a little
bit earlier some of these sort of combat
puzzles where you are just trying to
evade these enemies that will swarm you
and kill you by virtue of you know
pressing some buttons and locking them
in a room or doing something to lure
them into one area where you can trap
them so that you can get away so there
are a lot of puzzles in stray and no i
do not feel like they're difficult um
because i think that the game is very
intuitive uh there are certainly things
that like i stopped and was like hmm
what i'm supposed to do here
but for the most part i think that they
are easily understood and honestly
probably a uh a core of the game
how complex slash difficult are
platforming sections the platforming is
also very simple again in my experience
and i think that that is
because
the lines are so clear like if what i'm
doing right now is platforming
uh there are clear pathways this is
telling me that i can get up there from
here so i would jump across here it
looks like this is intentionally leading
me this way okay i can jump on the top
of that and then i'm gonna jump on that
and then in here and then in here surely
we can go in here because the lights led
me this way um so as long as you're
following like the lines of the world
and the light sources in the world the
platforming is
it's just it's like a very easy in-game
logic to follow the platforming has some
cool stuff where like you have to get
momentum to move things in certain ways
sometimes so you might have to jump on
the same pole three times in order to
get it to spin in one particular
direction so i do feel like it does some
cool smart stuff but it honestly is
pretty basic this is not a challenging
game does stray feel like a game anyone
and everyone could pick up and enjoy
regardless of gaming experience i would
think so yes there's very little ui
there's very little language um very
little dialogue
it's it's just a it's just a game where
you're a cat in a world
but i suppose it's hard to say if you
know some of the design stuff that i'm
talking about would be as obvious to
people who potentially haven't played a
lot of video games like again i see
something like this board this board is
telling me i can move in this direction
because of the angle that it's facing
i'm gonna run along this pipe and jump
up here we could jump up here and then
we could probably jump oh a collectible
up you get bud that is definitely a uh a
uh gameplay thing that you've just
witnessed here that i was going to bring
up as a negative
is occasionally just jumping on the
wrong things um and you can kind of go
around in circles sometimes it's just
difficult to like
have the x appear exactly where you
would like it to be
and i found that pretty consistently
throughout my time playing where i would
just accidentally jump up on the wrong
thing and have to like repeat that
process it's a it's a minor nitpick
but it's certainly something that
sometimes i was like come on dude
you know where i want you to go come on
so the other thing that kind of relates
to what you just said also look how cute
this is
because you're you're a cat you can't
knock sometimes some people you can only
get in their houses by scratching they
might not let me in though there are
again just a lot of cute things that are
very cat like that they've just done
such a good job of tying in the gameplay
it's like so satisfying to see so the
other thing that i was going to mention
as a potential
negative but more is a piece of advice
um that kind of ties to it being a game
anyone can pick up and enjoy
is that i think if you put this game
down and pick it back up several days
later weeks later
you might have a bit of trouble
the reason i say that is because unless
i've missed it there isn't an in-game
map and a lot of the time someone's like
hey just make sure you go back to what's
his face's house
and talk to what's his face again and
you'll be like oh [ __ ] where was what's
his face's house there are four main
locations that you will actually
probably need to go to frequently in
this sort of main location like this one
cute cat stuff uh this is grandma um i
had to go talk to her for a quest
to make some clothing
oh no we don't need to go down there
let me find a signpost real quick
here
you have the bottom and the spirit super
spirit laundry grandma clothing and
elliott programming
um and then obviously you just whichever
one of those is in which order you would
go to so it's just little street signs
let me go find the bottom man
he is up around this way
and obviously like you know i have been
playing this game i'm familiar with it
at this point so i do know where things
are so this is kind of a shop right here
you can uh buy stuff if you want to but
yeah there are some instances like you
need to go to sheamus place and talk to
sheamus again where
i
had not played the game in a day and had
already pretty much forgotten was like
[ __ ] where is that so i think that could
potentially be an issue the game
generally does a pretty good job but you
do need to pay attention to what people
are saying to you
um and a lot of the time you can't ask
people for advice so for example there
was somebody in this bar here i just
know where the bar is now thankfully who
said hey go find whoever's place it's
around the corner near this this and
this and this was it here it was the one
with all the uh signs on the door but
say if i left it for a few days and i
forgot that i was told that information
they won't necessarily tell you that
information again so you do need to pay
attention um and i could see that being
a floor in some people's eyes that it's
something that you actively need to be
like okay where am i supposed to be
going you can ask your drone for help
and it will tell you what your current
objective is so you do have that as a
reminder that like i said it can tell
you what your objective is or what
you're supposed to be doing but it
doesn't tell you where to go so not
knowing where someone's house is or
where someone is waiting for you can
still definitely be an issue especially
as the hardware locations only get
bigger and more complicated that said
you are going to be completely fine in
the more linear parts of the game how
satisfying is it to meow in stray
[Music]
i mean it's mostly just very cute
um
but the meow is used in gameplay like i
said
to lure enemies towards you for example
say there's some kind of barrier where
there are enemies on one side and the
other side and you need to try to group
them all together so you can get through
the other side um meowing would lure
them towards you so the meow is actually
very useful uh otherwise if you see
other
cats
they will meow and purr and the jewel
sense will vibrate when there's uh
purring and it's so cute
oh by by the way before i forget let me
show you this is um kind of your gun in
the game
um that uv light will take out the
enemies in areas that have them but
we're actually in a safe zone right now
how's the rioting considering we have a
silent protagonist in terms of
developing a story
i very much like the story uh again i
think a lot of it is told in world
building um you can of course talk to
people but there's not a lot of
conversation that you'll get out of them
i definitely feel like as the game went
on i was i was getting attached to
certain characters and certain people
but i feel like the writing is great in
terms of again that world building being
so rich i was very interested in what
had happened to the world in where i was
headed and why i was headed there so
i definitely appreciated the story i
think the best way to appreciate a story
for a lot of players is to be attached
to characters and i certainly was
attached to characters and their
outcomes and
also in some cases how they treated the
cat so
i would say they nailed that a lot of
people are asking how much control you
have in in stray as the cat like how
agility how much agility um
look it's not a ton like it can be like
this is me sort of free running right
here it's it can be sort of limited
there are some things that it feels like
you should be able to jump on that you
can't
i don't know how to answer that
exactly like i can't jump up there you
would think that i can but i'm not
allowed to jump up there um it's too far
apparently the gameplay is pretty
limited it's not at all complicated but
um yeah i don't feel like that's a
negative i think it does what it sets
out to do you get out or change one
thing about straight to make it more fun
what would it be that's a really
interesting question
i would probably say wall running but
you'd have to change so much of the game
to be able to do that how fluid is the
animation the trailers can seem a bit
stiff especially when there is a prompt
to jump somewhere else uh yeah there is
some stiffness to the animations
occasionally um like that prompt right
there obviously it's like a it's a bit
of a break i also just jumped the wrong
way um it can be a little bit stiff and
i will say i'm playing on a ps5 which to
me seems like a pretty good choice of
hardware
but uh
i did have a number of areas where there
were pretty bad frame rate drops as well
so just a technical issue
worth mentioning is um yeah frame rate
drops while doing some story stuff a lot
of the time look at him go
little cutie i feel like they nailed the
physics of the cat though like very very
impressed with it
also the scale of things like because
you are playing as a cat and other
things just like the size of a bin you
know things just feel so big it's it's
very endearing how many intense chase
sequences are there there are chase
sequences in stray but there's not an
overwhelming amount of them and it's
kind of just that the com the combat
sections in general
can be chase sequences you do have to
run away from these little critics that
are going to try and eat you and you can
attack them after running away from them
but uh because your uv light is on a
cooldown it'll blow and then you have to
wait for it to recharge
that would mean that you have to run
away often just like leading the little
guys around circles to dodge them and
once you shine the beam on them a bunch
of them will explode before your
cooldown catches up to you and i will
say this is definitely a weak part of
the game a lot of just backing up
waiting for a light to shine on some
enemies that unfortunately basically no
matter where you are in the game it's
just gonna feel the same and the way it
feels is not great it's not a great
strategy back up and shoot over and over
again definitely not a strong suit of
stray one thing i did keep wishing that
i could do was jump on the ground like i
just want to press x and jump so bad i
kept really wanting to do that
unfortunately
you've got
getting down can be a bit of a pain like
it seems like i should just be able to
jump down from here but i can't you have
to
sort of be a little bit more precise
about it um
finding your pathways down when we know
how far down cats can jump
that's definitely a thing that uh
sometimes feels overly restrictive like
really i can't jump down from here
really all right
my little sister really wants to know
straight is as cute as the trailer seem
to apply and if the cat is happy the cat
is very happy the game is very cute but
i do want to issue a warning that there
are some things that are really sad
including sad things that happened to
the cat including the cat limping
if it takes a big fall which broke my
heart so
um it could upset a ten-year-old person
who really likes cats there are
definitely some some little heart twinch
moments in this game wondering if stray
has any replay value uh
i would consider stray to be a more of a
one and done type experience um i tend
to prefer those to be honest uh so no i
would not consider straight i have a lot
of replay value i would think it's
probably just the one
the one sitting um it's something that i
could see myself revisiting in like a
few years after i've forgotten how some
of it goes because i enjoyed it so much
but it is gonna be more of a
one-and-done um type game where yeah the
only other thing you'd really have to do
after finishing the game is go and get
the collectibles and there's not a ton
of those and i think that is most of the
questions that i gathered from the
internet
um
yeah like i said i really really like
this game i'm only showing you this hub
world right now to avoid showing you
any more of the story so you can
experience it fresh so you can
experience the puzzles for yourself it
is definitely simple it's not going to
be a huge challenge for a lot of players
i don't think but it's very pleasant and
not in a way that just relies on you
being a cute little cat
it's uh it's a very heartfelt story
again like with some similarities to
nero automata if anyone's a fan of
platinum
i love the story in that game and there
are some things that are kind of like
that yeah it just it's a it could have
just been the cat gimmick game but it is
a lot better than that it's a short very
contained very tight experience that i
would definitely recommend i i really
really like it let me know if you have
any more questions embargo is up now so
we can answer them otherwise i'm alana
thank you for watching huge thanks to
annapurna for giving me a code i will
see you guys next time